what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves an
official trailer for
Ahsoka I heard John and I were featured
in the featurette which is cool I heard
we had a split second that's what I'm
talking about Star Wars so I'm talking
about Kathleen Kennedy everyone's hero
John how are you uh so can't wait for
this G top that koi uh so can't yeah
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen leave a like also
wanted to give a mention that Saturday
July 22nd
the real rejects us are going to be
having a Comic-Con panel 1pm so if
you're going to sdcc please attend our
panel come say hi take a photo with John
catch koi on his way out as he rushes to
his following panel leave a like uh and
yeah we'll be covering this show I can't
wait to watch it love me some Ahsoka
Tano you're gonna be doing a panel with
Rosario Dawson aren't you that's right
that's right so it is relevant to have
you here tomorrow all right
see what's going on
[Music]
it's inevitable
Must Destroy
in order to create
all right rest in peace no Jedi
I love the red logo I started hearing
whispers
of thrawn's return as heir to the Empire
God damn right damn what happens when we
find thrawn
bad stuff such as you've never dreamed
this looks great
I've spent most of my life fighting
Awards
trying to convince you to help me
prevent another one
dude and I both know who could help you
with this
stubborn as ever
I bet your master found you difficult at
times Anakin never got to finish my
training away from him just like I
walked away from Sabine you never made
things easy for me master
as a Jedi sometimes you have to make the
decision no one else can wait hold on
what's up doing my mind racial nice
haircut
as a Bridger animation in the background
I guess we have to do what's right
regardless of our person it's a close-up
on the answer version of the animation
there
was like actual Rebels animation a
little bit
if we don't stop throng everything oh
wow close-up he looks cool no power
Anakin spoke highly of you
here to discuss my past
we have a lot of work to do once a rebel
always a rebel goddamn right oh the
Mandalorian action there
aren't questioners are back
two episodes so premiere
cool I love that music wait a minute
it's been a long time since I've seen
Star Wars Rebels
um but there's in the trailer the part
that stood out to me the most is when
Sabine calls Ahsoka master so at the end
of rebels you know like a big part of
this is going to explore what have they
been up to since that ending of rebels
right when they were on the search for
Ezra Bridger and now if I recall
correctly I remember Sabine is she's
Force sensitive and she had some
training with Kanan but she never like
completed trade in order to become a
Jedi I've heard rumors that maybe down
the road should I become a Jedi but it
seems like they're setting her up here
in this series to eventually become a
Jedi and and for her to call her master
meaning she was being trained by Ahsoka
to become a Jedi
that's pretty crazy some crazy all
right that's like my one big question
mark there because that opens up a whole
new can of worms but uh yeah I'm loving
everything we're seeing with Sabine I'm
loving everything that we've still
barely got any Ezra Bridger here and uh
everything that we were seeing with uh
Mary Elizabeth uh Winstead as Hera uh
looks awesome too I think she's gonna
deliver a solid performance and uh yeah
this is I mean I'll save some general
thoughts for for you boys uh koi why
don't you spout some general thoughts uh
Ray Stevenson is always such a force and
to see him like open this trailer and
having you know we recently lost him I'm
really
encapsulated by being captivated by his
presence and everything so to see him as
this I mean it looks like a Sith Lord
looks like someone like very powerful
and dominating I don't know the
characters I'm really excited to meet
that world and it's a new characters
more comfortable than ever talking about
that one but this looks like uh you know
the scope of a movie which is what I
like about the Star Wars shows the
trailers really allow you to dive into a
world and I love the movies and and how
powerful and impactful they feel this
feels like something you sit down and
like watch at a theater with your family
so I loved the scope of this I loved how
the characters look large and powerful
and a lot of names I've heard throughout
Star Wars Lord getting to see them like
thrawn getting to see in live action
getting to see Mary Elizabeth Winstead's
character I'm I'm really excited to
expand the Galaxy beyond the Skywalkers
yeah that's what I'm saying yeah yeah
Johnny no absolutely and I mean this had
like a quality to it where it certainly
it feels at home among all the other
different shows and movies and stuff but
this does have its own sort of Sheen
about it that I don't know drew me in
quite a bit because it doesn't have the
same kind of Dusty grit as like a
Mandalorian but it still looks like
it'll be very sprawling and it'll be
like there's something about like the
daylight quality like you're just seeing
all this stuff like kind of in the Stark
light of day that I think also like you
know people talk about the volume and
how these shows are developing some sort
of look but this had like you said that
very striking cinematic quality it
looked like yeah a dramatic kind of you
know from what I understand about Rebels
there is a certain amount of that real
sort of harrowing uh you know grasp for
heroism and this looks like it'll
represent that struggle very well this
felt very tangible in a way that I think
could up the caliber for you know these
shows in the Star Wars Universe moving
forward I'm very excited to see thrawn
who is certainly going to be our Thanos
for whatever that movie is that they're
gonna be making and I'm sure you heard
about that movie at least right that
they're it's gonna be uh putting all
these shows together so that way we can
get some type of cinematic super
exciting like that is such a smart thing
for Star Wars fans I think it's really
exciting smarts that means thrawn's more
than likely going to survive uh this
season uh but for thrawn to be brought
to live action I'm enjoying the presence
of him and I think that for those who
aren't that familiar with him actually I
I read the there was a book that was
based on I think it is called heir to
the Empire and I read the comic
adaptation of it that is on as on the
Marvel unlimited app it's a Marvel comic
guys and I read the Marvel comic a
couple months ago where you see how he
got into the Empire and how he rose
through the ranks and you see just how
like of a cunning like genius he is and
I think that's the part of it where
people are going to be the most
surprised by if they're not that
familiar with thrawn because as menacing
as he is you teach us how sophisticated
uh intellectual artistic smart and uh
manipulative like there's these
fascinating qualities about the guy so
as much as we just look to see like
these teases and looks and these ominous
little looming uh areas that you see in
the shots of him I feel like the
performance requires a lot than just
look like a creep it's gonna be
something that I feel like will be
something very special uh so yeah man uh
I've I have a lot of faith in this Dave
filoni didn't do much work on
Mandalorian season three upon mistaken
because he was too busy putting this
whole what I hear is like like a
borderline Masterpiece at least like
people have seen it really upset like
it's pretty incredible so I'm excited to
see it guys what did you think about the
Ahsoka trailer leave your thoughts down
below thank you so much for being here
um leave a like and Hey listen to the
patreon
Brian Perry Brian my dude you seem like
the kind of guy we could put our faith
behind to save us from the machinations
of the Sith and the dark side all right
you got a nice star wars-esque name
which I think is perfect you can't get a
star war going without a good iconic
name Brian Perry four syllables like
Ahsoka Tano it's perfect my dude what
color lightsaber would you have how
would you wield the force and bring hope
to the Galaxy that's what I want to know
that's what I want to see because we are
now your padawans and you got all the
midichlorians my dude your Force levels
are off the charts so we are at your
service we are without fear we are one
with the force and the forces with us
but most of all we are one with your
pledge so keep it up buddy and we'll see
you next month thank you Brian